hi welcome to another cold fusion video
in the last episode we took a look at
how apple has started to move its
production of iphones
out of china and towards india and how
some of the new iphone 12s will be made
there
but today we're going to be looking at
the story of quippy
how do you go from almost raising 2
billion for a new video platform
hiring a massive amount of a-list actors
and creating a bunch of original content
only to just close down six months after
launching
this is the story of queebie the netflix
that never was
it's also the story of how the
differences in generations can affect
the world of business
let's take a look you are watching cold
fusion tv
unlike most recent startups the story of
quibby
starts with a baby boomer the platform
was the brainchild of seasoned
entertainment media mogul
jeffrey katzenberg the interesting thing
about the quibby story
wasn't that jeff didn't have the
experience to lead a great company
in fact it was the opposite he was a
management genius in the tv and movie
industry
[Music]
katenburg was born in 1950 in new york
coming from a well-off background being
the son of a stockbroker and an artist
he would start his career at paramount
pictures in the 1970s and quickly rose
through the ranks
in 1984 he would move to disney
disney's motion picture division at the
time was last in box office sales
but by 1987 jeff thrust them to number
one
he would go on to oversee hit tv shows
like the golden girls and home
improvement
jeff was only getting started though
when given the opportunity to revive
disney's flailing feature animation
department
he oversaw films like who framed roger
rabbit
beauty and the beast aladdin and the
lion king
basically he was great at his job and
whatever he touched
turned to gold jeff would then use his
professional insight to co-found
dreamworks in 1994 with steven spielberg
fast forward to 2018 and presumably
after seeing the success of both netflix
and mobile video consumption in all
forms jeff
saw an opportunity to carve out a market
of his own
the platform would be called quibby
which stood for
quick bites and it launched in april of
katzenberg would team up with former
ebay ceo meg whitman to explore this
vision
so what did quibby aim to do
in summary it was netflix for mobile
short form
streamed video content around 7 to 10
minutes long
but for mobile only because of jeff
katzenberg's previous achievements and
contacts in the entertainment industry
he managed to attract big names such as
jennifer lopez
steven spielberg idris elba dwayne the
rock johnson
zac efron kevin hart lebron james
liam hensworth chrissy teigen and the
list goes on
nbc universal sony viacom
warner media jp morgan alibaba
goldman sachs and of course disney threw
money at the project to invest
1.75 billion in total the quibby company
had a super bowl commercial before its
launch
and with 50 shows available at launch
they were ready to take the world by
storm
our use case which is now tried through
tested and proven the market is there
there are two billion people
who are watching an hour of short form
content
on the go every day around the globe if
we go out and capture
literally two percent
three percent of that addressable
audience we will have one of the great
blockbuster businesses of all time
unlike tiktok or the general youtube the
content was high production
slick and premium there were three
categories
reality tv shows documentaries or
original movies that were delivered in
10 minute chapters
the core vision of the project was that
users would watch these shows on a
commute to a bus or train station
they were so confident on this core idea
that there was no tv
option at launch
i bet by now you can already see a few
problems with this idea
betting on mobile commuters made their
target market specific
and small it was a huge risk at its core
for one people could just watch netflix
or youtube on the go
youtube has 2 billion users and you can
find whatever you want if you look hard
enough
quibby viewed their content as premium
and they would be charging five dollars
a month
for a subscription after a three month
trial but there's already a lot of
competition there
disney plus hbo max and apple tv just to
name a few
users didn't need another one but in
quibby's eyes
they had figured a gap in the market
there was no premium short form content
for mobile
the theory is that people are going to
be are going to want to watch
premium content hbo level quality
content on their phones
instead of tv in addition to tv in
addition to it if you're 25 to 30 years
old which is our core audience you get
up every day you leave your home and you
take a television set with you and
between
seven in the morning and seven and night
right now today
you're watching 70 minutes youtube
snapchat
instagram facebook watching this
and it's stuff's fantastic we think we
can bring
hollywood quality to that kind of
consumption
and bring a level of storytelling that
the creators in that world had never
been able to afford to do because they
didn't have the resources
and in a subscription service we
actually can do it and it's not
dissimilar to what hbo did in the 1990s
when
they came along and said we're not tv
we're hbo and we would say to you we're
not short form we're quibby
they expected 7 million users in the
first year
and 250 million dollars in subscriber
revenue in that year
but this proved to be a massive
miscalculation
by july they had over 1 million active
users but only 72
000 people had signed up to pay
it was clear that the company was in
trouble and needed to change and change
fast lockdowns had started to ramp up in
their launch month of april
and people weren't commuting anywhere in
october
kubi added support for tv they released
apps for amazon fire tv apple tv
and android tv as well as apple airplay
and google chromecast
but it was too little too late in just
six months
the decision was made to pull the plug
and the service was cancelled
now katzenberg blamed the catastrophic
failure on the coronavirus
but was this true what went wrong for
quibby
yeah what went wrong alexis i mean what
didn't go wrong
now if you ask katzenberg and whitman it
was the pandemic
and there was a sort of instantly viral
infamous interview he gave to the times
just over a month after quibby launched
in may where he said
i blame every single problem we've had
on coronavirus
but the problem with that thinking is it
assumes that without the pandemic this
would have been a big hit
i'm not sure there's any evidence of
that yes this played a part
but platforms like tick tock are mobile
only and if anything
they thrived during the first round of
lockdowns
as we mentioned going mobile first was a
risk but there's more to it
to begin users couldn't organically
share viral moments of video snippets
this is unlike tiktok which has their
brand logo at the bottom whenever
something's shared
giving them free viral marketing and on
that note
the marketing of qibi was subpar in
general i mean
how many of you have heard of people
using quibby and how many of you didn't
even know it existed
but it gets worse
[Music]
the biggest failure may have been the
content itself although some reviews
noted that there was good content on the
platform
it may just be that traditional
celebrities are falling out of favor
especially for mobile content they're
just not as big as they were
10 to 20 years ago people no longer
perceive them as genuine
organically grown content is becoming
king young people are no longer obsessed
with the slick hollywood media that a
billion dollar boomer startup could
provide
kuby proves that you can't buy your way
into what's perceived as cool
the newest generation finds its stars on
tiktok
youtube and instagram it's a crowd-led
democracy on what's popular
and you can't buy that to jeff
katzenberg
this has never been the case in his
professional career in his heyday
tv magazines and even radio was king
in short young millennials and gen z
just didn't care enough to pay five
dollars per month
to see celebrities in short form content
jeff katzenberg will return 300 million
of the 1.7 billion raised and may
liquidate assets
this is a contrast to firms such as
wework and theranos
and allegedly nikola motors he tried to
keep the lie going as long as possible
so that's a plus for jeff why did you
decide to shut down quibby now
rather than at the first signs of
problems with adoption or rather than
wait and continue to try for longer it
was clear
that uh for whatever reason this was not
going to be as successful as jeffrey and
i had hoped
and so we took stock of where we were
and we said the best thing to do
the honorable thing to do is to return
money to shareholders
when we knew this was not going to have
a path forward as a viable stand-alone
business
so we feel like we made the right
decision a very difficult decision but
the right one for shareholders
so what can we learn here well firstly
quibby didn't understand their market or
audience forcing mobile first because it
was your vision
is forcing the audience to come to you
it's probably better to always go to
your audience if possible
secondly know how to deliver to the
audience kubi had the money
but when they saw that the hollywood
crowd probably wasn't working
they could have just looked to existing
social media influencers
it would have been cheaper and got at
least some of the influencers audience
to join the platform
and lastly lack of flexibility quibby
could have postponed the launch
or change to a freemium model or change
from mobile only to tv
much earlier though i have to say like
anything in this world
it's very easy to criticize but much
harder to build and create
though it's interesting to wonder what
would you have done differently if you
were in charge
i think we thought there would be easier
uh
adoption by people uh to it um
i think that the environment that we
found ourselves in as you've heard us
say many times this was designed for
on the go in between at a moment in time
in which no one was on the go they're
still not on the go and
so our product market fit was wrong i
mean
somewhere between the idea being less
than perfect which we
we own and the environment we found
ourselves in
is where the fail has come what each of
those are in that equation
i'm not sure any of us are ever going to
know but it didn't work
but as i asked earlier if you were in
charge
what would you have done differently you
can discuss in the comment section below
for the past two episodes i did say that
the next one would be on huawei
the video's almost been finished for a
while but i've been having some
conversations with some huawei staff to
get their side of the story
i wanted it to be a fair video that
expresses both sides of the controversy
and this aspect of the back and forth
conversations with huawei is taking some
time
but don't worry the video is still
coming anyway that's about it from me
you've been watching cold fusion and my
name is tagogo and i'll see you again
soon
for the next episode cheers guys have a
good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]
you